ich
bin viel trainieren und die ungenannt im
geräte zur technischen kompanie hinter
mäßig zu die diese räume die 500 und die
dadurch hätten eher vorstellen und
deshalb bei der kult mit dem wir
aufschlagen bis 15 und das ganze
funktioniert wie so ein zweitaktmotor
das heißt der kolben fällt nach unten es
bisher keine einspritzung eine explosion
der kolben wird dann nach oben befördert
und falls selbstständig wieder nach
unten dadurch können wir fehler oder wie
wir dazu sagen piloten in die erde
rammen
das gerüst wurde dieser rahmen fixiert
ist nennt sich mäckler und grundgerüst
ist circa zwölf meter hoch und alles im
einen hat zirka 3300 kilogramm
zwei jahren einen kameraden
eingeschlagen eingerannt sind vier meter
tief in der erde darin wirtschaft ist
fertig aus und da kann man dann oben
eine brücke oder je nachdem an den steg
darauf setzen
die vollen und sonnige grüße aus wie
lange er sein
[Musik]